what's up guys
bang bang lunch money time monday
morning
good morning well while she's trying to
get rich the rest of us just trying to
get our lunch money right i'm here with
the intelligent and beautiful
paulina ivalova marinova pompliano
p-i-m-p
in the house what's up p-i-m-p in the
house
bang bang uh the show is sponsored by
blockfi
as you guys all know i'm an investor in
the company and a big
fan of what they do they've got three
products you can buy and sell
cryptocurrencies you can deposit crypto
and take out a us dollar loan against
your deposit
or you can deposit crypto or stablecoin
and earn up to 8.6
apy in an interest-bearing account and
do you know what they're doing today
what are they doing today anthony they
actually started sponsoring
dave portnoy's uh davie day trader show
oh we were okay hold on a second okay
you can't be mixing brands like that oh
no see gemini
is the people who custody the assets for
block five so you guys didn't see that
but i was ready to go the very nice
people over at gemini sent me this hat
i like it it's slick i look good in it
probably at least that's what plina told
me
all right let's get into oh and by the
way i'm also uh i've got the profile
that's what i was talking about right
here everyone go subscribe to planet's
newsletter at readtheprofile.com
what's up with the uh news big week big
week
big week did your voice just this week
week big week
all right what's up um okay things in
belarus are
getting serious so the other day we
actually walked across the street there
were a ton of people
and it was uh people pro there were
protesters and there were there were
people voting
basically in belarus the election was
very rigged
very being the operative word and now
the belarusian president has rejected
calls to quit
following his contested re-election
warming that warning
that the former soviet republic would
perish as a state if it was
forced to repeat the vote in opposition
protesters took to the street
for the eighth consecutive day of
anti-government demonstrations
i feel like this guy just stole the
election it seems like
and then everyone called him on it he
has been in power since 1994.
yeah i mean that's probably that's like
dictator type stuff he claimed a
landslide victory by the way to get a
sixth term and has denied allegations of
fraud
until you kill me there will be no other
elections he told workers at a tractor
plant on monday
listen you could say that and we could
laugh in the united states but you can't
say that in eastern european countries
and
and not expect somebody to at least try
to kill you the only dictatorship that
exists in this household
is in this household i am you're a
dictator until you kill me
i hope there will be no other
dictatorship okay let's move on to the
next topic i don't like this
conversation anymore
what's up guys um all right so uh-oh
so russia's vaccine chief claims that
the west is trying to lure
away its scientists wait what
yeah basically the head of russian's
vaccine development body has claimed
that western research institutions are
seeking to lure away
its scientists to work for them and it
wants to poach
scientists from russia to work in europe
and the u.s had not worked
it's this makes no sense they said our
researchers have been working at the
gamalea institute for 10 years any
american or european university can only
dream of having such researchers
and they are seeking to lure them away
but they won't be able to
okay he also offered no evidence so yeah
i feel like there's a lot of propaganda
maybe
floating around from all sides uh did
you ever watch the doping
aquarius i carry this icarus
it's a netflix documentary i started it
but it was kind of boring and then i
got confused it's all about uh the
russians who
basically figured out how to do doping
uh before everybody else
and they used it to help athletes become
uh much more athletic
um and so i feel like they're always
been like very science-heavy you know i
never met a russian who didn't know good
math and science
right that's a stereotype is it yeah
do you know any russians russians who
are amazing poets but do they also know
math and science
yes
[Laughter]
i'm just saying my personal experience
i'm from bulgaria and i'm bad at math
and science
but you were good before you left yeah
but like
when you showed up here in fourth grade
didn't you weren't they all doing
addition
and you were like doing solving for that
i'm doing calculus guys
all right that's fine but by the way uh
russia may or may not have a vaccine
i'm just not taking it right like i feel
like that's a whole nother thing that
people are forgetting it's not like you
have to take the vacation okay but but
how about this how about this because
russia is so good at science and math
why wouldn't you trust this vaccine no
it's just because i don't take
like most vaccines like i don't take the
flu shot okay
okay hold on hold on a flu shot is
different from a vaccine you have a lot
of vaccines
because you can't you weren't able to go
to school
i definitely have been forced to take
them in the army i had to do it whatever
but i'm just saying in general i'm not
like oh let me go get
shots of things in my body right so the
flu shot other types of things
if i can avoid it which you always you
can't always so nervous if you can i try
to avoid it i'm so nervous for flu
season like people are gonna
be getting sick and they won't know is
this the flu is this the
the what's it called covid you forgot
the name of the
virus that is forced to sit inside for
23 hours i'm trying to forget it guys my
birthday's next week
oh is it next week yeah yeah was it the
22nd
fourth oh i knew that all right what's
the next topic
sanofi agreed to acquire u.s biotech
company principia
biopharma for about 3.4 billion dollars
as the french drug maker pivots towards
the innovative therapies to spur growth
under the new ceo paul hudson i think
this is the second
largest deal in biopharma
or something yeah well they do
treatments for multiple sclerosis
and a range of autoimmunity they're also
working on a vaccine but
this is the second largest by uh
pharmaceutical acquisition this year
after gilead sciences agreed to pay 4.9
billion
by cancer therapy maker 47 in march
what's crazy to me is the stock price of
this company's gone up 66 percent this
year
and then sanofi stepped in and they
agreed to pay 10 premium to friday's
closing price
no no but they just agreed to pay a 10
premium oh yeah
so it had already gone up 66 now i have
a hot take
i feel like the medical industry is
going through what like the dot-com
companies did and the blockchain
companies it's just like if all of a
sudden you're like oh we're working on a
vaccine
oh that's all you have to say and then
everyone's like oh that company's hot
and they just explode in value
yeah so you agree with me it happens
everywhere yeah so you're agreeing with
me yes
all right so it's not such a hot take
it's not hot take oh all right
i just i just feel like look for new hot
takes where i disagree with you
i just feel like they're going through
this like this hype cycle boom
every every industry goes through us
hype psycho do you remember when in
media
everybody that was doing social media
like kept getting bought
in like 2008 2009 um
like buzzfeed was really hot they
figured out social and then like a bunch
of other ones
okay that's fair i'll think of more all
right that's fine but by the way the
pharmaceutical hype cycle means that uh
it's compounded with uh people don't
understand the science so you can say
all kinds of crazy stuff
and then people are just like oh yeah
sure whatever like i don't understand
science because i'm not russian
you don't understand the other day i had
to explain to him basic
english grammatical rules no whoa hold
on
rewind there's most people i write every
single day my brother writes every day
now palina writes every day
i know a lot of people who write every
day polina started telling me things
about propositional phrases
oh my god and pronouns and all this
stuff and i told her look i know what a
noun is i know what a verb is i know
what an adjective is but that's pretty
much where i
know what a pronoun is guys well i was
like what's the pro part of the pronoun
like why don't you just call it a noun
because it's not a noun it's a proper
noun
yeah i see but like that's stupid then
uh what was the prepositional phrase
he was trying to stick a word in between
two things that should never be
separated
do you want to know why i'm a good
writer
it's cause i just write how i talk
everyone else is trying to sit there and
do all the like
stuff i just write how i talk it's
soothing to the brain of someone who's
reading if they don't have to be broken
up in the middle of a sentence by a word
that
should not be there okay ready i like to
use my
vast knowledge and command of the
american language
okay speaking of covet and vaccines
the fda authorized emergency use of a
new and inexpensive saliva test
for covid that could greatly expand
testing capacity
because up until now they're sticking
things up your nose and
actually that first of all the saliva
test would be a much less invasive
process
obviously than the nasal swabs and
it also avoids the a key step that has
caused shortages of chemical regions
used in other tests can and it can run
approximately 90 samples
in fewer than three hours in a lab so
yale school of public health developed
this
it's called saliva direct what's not in
this article because this article is
from acquired
news.com yes that news.com is just
reporting the science part of it but
what no one
uh is saying in the medical community is
that this was actually funded i believe
or partially funded by the nba
nba yeah the national basketball
association had their hand in doing this
they were they were driving a lot of it
uh mainly because
uh just like do control f nba
let's see what happens well you have to
spell nba oh yeah the research team
validated saliva direct in part by
testing nba players coaches and staff
and yell said the test is now being
studied in asymptomatic people
through the program with the nba and its
players union whoa
look at that it's like i read the
internet i know things before she even
reads
you read joseph's newsletter nope jose
didn't talk about this
but uh yeah i mean look at the end of
the day this is
exactly what people need right is they
need an easy way to get the test
shooting your head with better data
better numbers better results
shooting people's heads with the little
guns that tell you your temperature
doesn't matter
i'm like what score am i gonna get now
what score is like a competition it's
actually the opposite
i always get the best score best
temperature nobody's ever gotten better
temperature than me
all right what's the next topic all
right so you know rent the runway yes
i am wearing rent the runway as we speak
this is not an endorsement they do not
sponsor me
although they should um so the clothing
rental startup
rent the runway is closing all of its
stores for good
and it's going instead it's focusing on
its network of drop boxes so there's a
number of
drop boxes it has in the city and you
can go
take your clothes there drop them in the
box scan them
and then you get new clothes i i one
time went in a rent the runway store
was like i have to drop this off i was
like what is that she had like a bag and
i was like is there drugs in there like
what like what do you mean you have to
drop it off and she was like no we go to
this place and i drop it and i was like
that sounds like a drug drop
no you scanned them in for me one no i
know but but you were like
we gotta go into this store so i went
with her and she was
uh mid the right and there's like these
two boxes and she was showing me how it
works or whatever and i was like oh
that's pretty cool
so i mean i scanned one or two of them
whatever saw make sure that the
technology works
and then i turned around and there's
like a store it's like a retail store
and there was a
madhouse it was chaos in this place and
so all those chaos because you have
until exactly i think it's 3 p.m
to return things to get other close
ships the same day so girls are like oh
my god oh my god i have two minutes left
let me
they're like drug addicts literally
because you're doing a drug drop and
they're drug addicts
uh it's just this time it's not illegal
drugs it is it literally looks like a
zombie town if you're in around the rent
the runway area at like 259
you just see a bunch of girls with their
heads down on their phone it's really
creepy
yeah it's pretty crazy so i went inside
uh i don't understand
where demand went other than the virus
obviously uh because this place was
packed and it looked like there was
never gonna be a shortage of people who
wanted to get close well no
now people don't have to wear clothes
like i don't have to wear clothes
that might go into the lunch money hall
of fame of quotes
now people don't have to wear clothes
they don't have to wear different
clothes all the time the reason i have
to is because i'm a star and like if i
wore
the same thing like he does every day
you guys would call me out and i know
better than that because i'm not um
okay so read the wrong way closing all
their stores it's great business
it'll be fine uh so i actually don't
think it's a great business because
hot take well they've struggled to get
the business model right for a long time
hot take and uh now what they're doing
is i think it's smart of them to close
the physical locations because that was
stupid i mean
girls would only go in there not only
the majority of people
would go in there to uh drop off their
clothes
they're it was slim pickings at the
store because if you like something on
the shelf they only have a few different
sizes so if you're not one of those
sizes it's like tough luck
but this way the whole point is i want
to get my size i want to get what i like
and i want to get it delivered same day
so that's what they're doing do you
think i should start a rent or runway
for black t-shirts
no designer black tea does that kind of
ruin the problem
it ruins the problem yes it does not
solve the problem
it makes it worse same difference all
right what's up pentagon pentagon ufos
the pentagon is forming a new task force
to investigate ufos okay at this point
why don't we just say that they're
aliens because ufos and aliens are
different i know but there's
trying to explain the task force that
will be overseen by the department of
the navy
and will report to the office of the
under secretary of defense for
intelligence and security
yet yeah that's it so what are they
going to do they're gonna
they're gonna investigate unexplained
aerial incidents encountered by the us
military the creation of the
unidentified aerial phenomena
task force or uaptf continues an effort
to begin that began in recent years to
investigate unexplained aerial incidents
encountered by the us military
so at the end of the day
i actually don't think that the ufo
incidents are going to
lead to any alien discoveries why
because again
they're two different things i
understand but if if we don't have
that kind of thing in the uh in the us
in like on earth the way it can dart
back and forth like that
yes it's a ufo it's not an alien but
wasn't it created by
something else that we can't create here
no it's like the first person who ever
saw a plane they were like what the hell
is that thing oh okay
right and then somebody else was like oh
i created it this is how it works
so it's just like we don't understand
something right now and by the way
from the videos it's not like they got
their hands on they're like oh we can't
like figure this out right they just saw
it and then on top of it do you think
it's more likely that aliens have these
uh
unidentified china 16 year old in utah
[Laughter]
right so it's just like like we don't
know is the short answer yeah uh but on
top of that
that doesn't necessarily mean that
aliens aren't real i am a believer in
aliens i believe that they're out there
somewhere they may even be here on earth
and we just can't see them
or it may be on a different time what
would you do if you found out i'm an
alien
oh i already know that yeah planet one
time asked me if i ran into like an
alien like a little green man what would
i do and i said i'd just go to the bar
and get a beer with them he did say that
hey man come on let's go little buddy
like what does go and chill um and
here's the thing and then i would hit
him with please be nice to me please be
nice to me
okay you're not in star trek i never
watched star trek i didn't either or
star wars
i've never seen either one i think i saw
a little bit of star wars so guys
they're gonna judge us anthony i don't
care look i just don't like it oh but my
dad evo loves star wars he's obsessed
with star wars
we need to bring evil back on the show
you do all right so uh what would you do
if you were part of this task force and
you found
a ufo no a ufo oh wait a ufo yeah
i would research it i would call all the
16 year olds in utah that i know
and i'd be like listen did you have
anything because think about it if you
know 16 year olds in utah no but think
about it if somebody had seen
tick tock for the first time and they
saw these weird dances they'd be like
okay that's definitely are you are you
comparing tick-tock and ufos
because nobody's seen people move like
that before
it's jarring to the eye you must have
missed the 70s
oh yeah that's true i didn't miss the
70s thank god
yeah a little john travolta action don't
look at my jokes
all right what joke you got come on all
right oh my god we've done a lot of
these to be honest with you because you
keep going to bestlifeonline.com
what do you call a cow with two legs a
cow with two legs
it's actually kind of stupid it should
be a skinny cow what do you call a
skinny cow
i just changed the joke what do i call a
skinny cow with two legs
yeah i got foot loose
no lean beef
lean beef what's the point of missing
the two legs well i i think that was
stupid that's why i changed the joke to
a
thin cow with four legs what do you call
a joke you make in the shower
a joke i make in the shower a clean joke
[Laughter]
see i'm the one with the real jokes
that's it for lunch monday today
while the rest wait what is it well wall
street's trying to get rich the rest of
us is trying to get our lunch money
right
literally i almost messed that up i know
what's going on with my hair janae
i ain't gonna make no comments that was
bait guys i'm not taking it that's it
for today we'll see you guys tomorrow
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that you can click on
i'm an investor a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block flies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polena they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to eight point six percent
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange i personally
use the interest bearing account there's
not very many places where you'll find
up to eight point six percent interest
on a deposit in an interest bearing
account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but eight point six percent
is pretty compelling
so click on the link in the description
say thanks to the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends